انتقلت وكاله رويترز عن المستشار الالماني
اولاف شولد قوله ان امنه طاقه لهذا الشتاء
بات مضمونا واضاف شولدس ان بلاده تسعى
لتجنب الاخفاقات في سياسات الطاقه
والتجاره التي ادت بهم الى الاعتماد على
روسيا والصين بالشكل الخاص
معنا من امام البند الصاج الالماني في
برلين مراسلون عيسى طبيعي عيسى اذا امن
الطاقه مضمون حسب الشغل ما الذي يقال او
يقوله منهم في المجال في الميدان
نعم بحسب وزاره الاقتصاد ايضا وبحسب ايضا
البيانات التي اصدرتها ااا الوكاله
الفيدراليه للشبكات بان امن الطاقه اصبح
مضمونا مخازن همم مشاهده تخزين الغاز
الطبيعي في المانيا جميعها ممتلئه لكن ما
اشار اليه المستشار اليوم المستشار هي
اشار الى عده النقاط جديده ومثيره الحقيقه
في مساله من الطاقه اليوم قدم المستشار
مشروع ميزانيته للعام المقبل 2023 ولذلك
كان المفاجاه هو انه قال بان جميع المحطات
الجديده للطاقه في شمال المانيا ستبدا
بصوره مفاجاه العمل خلال اسابيع قليله
مقبله كنا نتحدث عن المنشاه الوحيده التي
تم الاعلان عنها وهي نائمه او او الرصيف
العائم الذي سيبدا خلال الاسابيع لكن عن
المستشار تحدث عن جميع المنشات بانها
ستدخل في القمه في الخدمه عفوا والامر
الثاني الذي اشار اليه بان المستشار اكد
بان حكومته قامت باكبر عمليه اصلاح وتجديد
لمنظومه الطاقه في المانيا وهو الامر الذي
وصفه بانه تاريخي لم يسبق اليه في منذ
انشاء الجمهوريه الالمانيه ما بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه يتحدث ايضا المستشار
شولت بان الاستغناء عن امدادات الطاقه
الروسيه
اصبحت كاملا وقال بان العام الماضي كان
الاعتماد على الغاز الروسي وصل الى 50%
ورد على زعيم المعارضه فريدريش مارس قائل
له بان حكومته خلال 12 شهرا استطاعت ان
تحزمها وعن تضمن امدادات الطاقه للبلاد
فيما عجزت عنه الحكومات السابقه منذ 12
عاما هكذا وصفه ايضا بان ما قدمه زعيم
المعارضه و هو رئيس الاتحاد المسيحي
الديمقراطي الذي كانت تتزحمه المستشار
الملكه قال بان الهجوم الذي سبق بكلمته
كلمه المستشار قال بانه محظوراء وبان هذه
الحكومه هي الحكومه الوحيده في تاريخ
المانيا لا يستطيع التي استطاعت ان تؤمن
مجال الطاقه للبلاد بشكل واسع وبدائل لم
تكن معهوده في بلاد ايضا تحدث عن نقطه
اوروبيه مهمه قال بان اوروبا بان المانيا
استطاعت ان تقود اوروبا الى وحده نسويه
استراتيجيه فيما عجز عنه الرئيس الفرنسي
منذ عقود نعم نعم همم